so yeah this is some work I did with
riot and over the past year yeah so I
guess to get started what is the hammock
nearest neighbor problem it's it's this
problem of you're given a set of end
database voice of dimension small D and
we want to like do some kind of
pre-processing of D so that later when
we're giving a query vector Q of the
same dimension we can answer this this
question of which was the database point
they were originally given with Smalling
håmüs Hamming distance to the query
point so you can tell this is like a
really important problem throughout
computer science like it comes up
through searching things and error
correction and with this in mind there's
this really unfortunate lower bound it's
called like the curse of dimensionality
sometimes by Farkle and rabbani that
basically only like trivial solutions to
this problem work so either you solution
where you like at the beginning you
store all the answers to all the
possible queries and it takes to the D
space or the solution we're like on an
input query you just compute all the
Hamming distance and it takes about end
time so basically there's there's
nothing there no great things we could
do for this problem but sort of sins
it's so important people have come up
with sort of ways around this curse of
dimensionality so a big one is to look
for approximate solutions so instead of
finding the nearest neighbor in the
Hamming distance you've one of just find
one which is within an epsilon fraction
of an epsilon factor of optimal and this
this like work on these approximate
solutions has had lots of beautiful
results big things like hashing and
dimensionality reduction came out of
here but unfortunately uh antonian dick
and Petrescu still showed that there's
this like curse of approximation instead
of curse of dimensionality that comes up
here and if i think this is in like the
cell probe model where you're given a
constant number of
per query you can show that you still
need like exponential and epsilon space
to solve this problem so there's still
like some big exponential lower balance
here another another sort of way around
this problem that that's become popular
pretty recently is to study this like
planted version of the problem where
instead of instead of sort of looking at
the worst case problem you're instead
given that all the vectors are like
uniformly random 01 vectors except
there's one planted pair of vectors with
Hamming distance much smaller than you
would expect and actually I Greg valiant
a couple of years ago came up with a
really deep end to the 1.6 to time
algorithm for this using some facts fast
matrix multiplication tricks that was
which is especially me because the the
running time is independent of what the
dimension of the vector it ends up being
but nonetheless I guess we wanted to
focus on the exact original problem and
we instead focused on sort of a natural
offline version of the problem so I got
a batch Hamming nearest neighbors
problem so here you're given the set of
and database points in dimension small D
again and you're also given a set of 2 u
of n query points all at once and you
want to find the herring nearest hemming
nearest neighbor of each of the query
points from the database d so what we
basically want to answer any of these
queries at the same time and this is
this is a nice problem to consider
because sort of the lower bounds I talk
to you about before don't don't apply
anymore in this offline setting but
nonetheless pretty recently best known
solution so this we're still like the
trivial ones like you either build the
table of all the possible answers for D
and then just look up everything in
queue or you like compute the Hamming
distance of each of the pairs and
squared times did something time so I
guess our big result that we got on this
problem is this so we basically if we're
solving this batch having nearest
neighbors problem in dimension D is like
see
log N and C can be a function of end but
it's it's probably easiest to think
about it acts like a constant or like a
like a log or something so and in a
sense I think login is sort of the
interesting dimension to consider this
problem in then we can solve a batch of
n hemming nearest neighbor queries on D
in 2 to the N minus 1 over order C log
squared C time with high probability so
when see actually is a constant when the
dimension of the vectors is log in then
this is a truly sub quadratic time
algorithm for like given the constant
there's an epsilon greater than 0 so
this runs in 2 to the end to the 2 minus
epsilon time and this is the first
algorithm like this that we really know
of but it improves on the trivial
algorithm even when d is like an order N
squared over log log squared n and
another really cool thing about this
algorithm is that our techniques we use
are really really different from past
work on this problem so I'll probably
about this for the rest of the talk but
basically we're going to use some cool
applications of probabilistic
polynomials to compute a lot of Hamming
distance quickly and this is like very
different from what people have tried
before and the last thing to note about
this is that well we also proved assess
lower bound on this problem so what we
show is that if there's an epsilon
greater than 0 such that for any
constant C you can solve this in like 2
n 2 the 2 minus epsilon time that would
violate the strong exponential time
hypothesis so yeah to be really clear
about this we get that for any constant
C there exists an epsilon but if we
instead show that there exists an
epsilon for every constancy that would
violate Seth so like with this in mind
there's sort of there's like a potential
limit to how well you can do on this
problem and like maybe you can't do very
much better than then what we got all
right so with that in mind I'm now going
to sort of shift gears completely for a
little bit and tell you about
polynomials and then at the end of the
talk will come back to how to use
polynomials to sell
this problem so yeah the question is
right how r power polynomial is relevant
at all and the the nice thing about
polynomials that sort of we've seen over
and over during this workshop is that
you could use them to compute boolean
functions so if you pick let R be your
favorite ring we're usually going to use
Z or Z mod something for this talk then
you say a polynomial P in n variables
over the ring computes the boolean
function f if for each possible 01
vector as input the polynomial evaluated
at the double zero and vector is equal
to the boolean function f at 0 and
vector so for a quick example if you
look at the or function the lower
function is like 0 if all the inputs are
0 or 1 otherwise right then it's equal
to this polynomial P here 1 minus the
product of 1 minus X I and you can see
like if all the excise are 0 then this
is 1 minus a product of one so it's 1
minus one is zero and if at least one of
the excise is one then that term of this
product will be zero so the whole
product is zero and it's 1-0 which is 1
so this polynomial exactly computes the
or function and yeah you can check this
polynomial has degree n and 22 then I
think actually two to the N minus 1 like
monomials when you expand out this whole
product here so add important thing
about polynomials for boolean functions
is that they you never need to take a
power of a variable greater than one
because since we're only substituting in
zero or one like x is equal to x squared
when x is either 0 or 1 so in other
words we only need to look at multi
linear polynomials for computing boolean
functions so the degree can be at most n
and there can be at most 2 to the n
terms so in some sense this or
polynomial is like as big as possible
and for our algorithmic applications
later we're going to be looking for
small polynomial so this is really bad
and like you might hope maybe we can be
more clever and come up with a better or
polynomial but it's it's not too hard to
see that any boolean function has a
unique polynomial representation so we
couldn't do that so I guess just like
sort of in algorithms
might look at probabilistic algorithms
to speed up or use a little less space
or something similarly we're going to
look to probabilistic polynomials to try
to help us find smaller polynomials so I
guess we've seen this definition a
couple times already too but a
probabilistic polynomial is in addition
to having like a degree primary rd
there's also an error parameter epsilon
and it's actually instead of just being
one polynomial it's a distribution with
squiggly be over polynomials and it
computes the boolean function f if the
probability over drawing a polynomial p
from the distribution that the
polynomial evaluated and an input x is
equal to the boolean function that
evaluated X is at least 1 minus epsilon
for every possible input X so yet this
is really important the probability is
over drawing a polynomial from the
distribution but this is a worst-case
over inputs X so I guess later on when
like we need our algorithm to have a
good chance of being right on any input
this property is going to be important
so let me give you an example of one of
these I'm going to tell you about a
probabilistic polynomial for or over the
integers which is by these guys from
1993 like 20 years ago so typically how
you construct one of these probabilistic
polynomials is you like define a sum
randomized algorithm which produces a
polynomial at the end and then like the
distribution of what this algorithm
might give you defines your distribution
over polynomials so here the I guess
randomized input to our algorithm is
going to be these sets s sub I so well
let s 0 be the set of 1 through n and
then for each I from one too long again
we're long again plus 1 we're going to
let si be the set where you start with
Si minus 1 and then keep each element
that's there with probability one-half
so like s0 has all n elements s1 will
have about half of them as two will have
about a quarter of them and so on then
for each of those I will define this
like intermediate polynomial piece of I
of X is the sum over
just the Jays in that set s of I of XJ
and then our probabilistic polynomial
for or is going to look like this you
can see it has some similar structure to
our or polynomial from before that's
like what minus a product of what mine
is something's so yeah I guess this you
can tell this always has degree like log
n so it's definitely a log n degree
probabilistic polynomial so let's see
why this actually is for the or function
yeah so first of all if the input is the
all zeros vector then each of these
pieces of ice is just the sum of zero so
it's 0 and this is 1 minus a product of
once which is 0 just like we want so
what we need to show or what I'm going
to show is that for any other input X
with at least no one in it this
polynomial I'll evaluate on X has at
least a one-third chance of outputting a
1 so and to show this also there's at
least a one-third chance that there's
some I for which p sub i is 1 because
then that term in this product will be 0
and so it'll be 1 minus 0 which is one
like we want and so this is sort of like
a really basic probability kind of
argument like so so what what's going on
at the beginning p sub 0 of x is just
the sum of all the entries of X because
s sub 0 is the whole set so pieces of 0
is just the number of ones in our input
vector and then log n plus 1 times we
like whatever number we have so far we
flip that many coins and whatever a
number of heads we get we write that new
number down and the question is are we
ever going to get a 1 if we do the
sequence so sorry have the two the two
bad things that can happen our first we
could start with a really big number
like the biggest we can start with his n
and then we do this the log n plus 1
times but still at the end we haven't
gotten small enough to get to one yet
like we're still at at least two but
since you can tell like since we're
flipping long n plus 1 times like the
probability we don't get to one is at
most a half say so the other bad thing
that can happen is we do get like all
the way to 0 but like at some point
we're at to or greater and we skip
straight to 0 with
going through one and there you can tell
like but if you have two or more coins
and conditioned on getting it like going
to either 0 or 1 the probability that
you go to one is at least two-thirds
like some basic probability so in total
the probability that will get a 1 in
this sequence this is least a half times
two-thirds which is a third which is a
number here and this works for any X no
matter what the excellent yeah so you
might be thinking all right this is not
so great like we have a polynomial that
only gives the right answer a third of
the time but there were only two choices
so that's not very helpful but you can
see that the error here is one to cite
it like if the answer is supposed to be
zero we always give 0 and if fans are
supposed to be one we give one a third
of the time so if you take like log 1
over epsilon draws from this
distribution and then just like plug
them into our exact polynomial for or
from before then you can get a degree
log in log 1 over epsilon polynomial
that has ever at any epsilon that you
want so this is really good because like
before our polynomial for overhead
degree n and now our polynomial has
degree log in this is an exponential
decrease in the degree and in fact if
you look over like the integers mod 2
instead you can you can even get rid of
this log n factor by a nice our
agreement by r as broadband small ski so
so this is like a huge savings so i
guess the poly the boolean function that
we really care about for our having
nearest neighbor problem is the majority
function and i'll explain more about why
this is later but sort of the intuition
is that when you're computing the
Hamming distance of two vectors you're
like counting the number of places in
which they differ and similarly majority
is like counting the number of ones in
your vector and seeing if it's at least
half so that's sort of the idea but i'll
make it more clear later so the function
we care about is the majority function
yeah just some notation but like
magnitude of X will be the number of
ones in the vector
and then the majority function is just
one if that magnitudes of least and over
to unfortunately like as I think we even
talked about in the last talked there's
this theorem by raj bhavan smolensky
from 87 which says that a probabilistic
polynomial for majority requires degree
root n log 1 over epsilon so we
definitely can't get like exponential
decrease in the degree here the best we
could hope for is like some square root
decrease in the degree ah yeah so this
is kind of unfortunate and I guess has
prevented a lot of work with
probabilistic polynomials for majority
in the past a little bit but we're going
to continue anyway and actually show
that there is a probabilistic polynomial
firm majority with this same degree root
n log 1 over epsilon so this and this
this degree will turn out to be like
exactly what we want for our application
like any bigger would have been too big
I guess yeah so what was that was the
past work on this problem I guess ah yes
sreenivasan worked on a slightly more
general problem where he was looking for
probabilistic polynomials for what are
called w some determined functions which
are the deterrent by some weighted sum
of the inputs and if you if you apply
his but what he would get by looking at
the majority function there you get
degree root n log 1 over epsilon times
some poly log n factor and that'll turn
out to be too big for our application
here yeah so okay so let me let me tell
you how our construction works and we're
actually gonna look at the threshold
function so its parameters by theta and
it's one if like the fraction of ones in
the vector is at least theta so in
particular the majority function is this
with theta equals a half so yeah I guess
the details here are very tricky but I'm
going to try to give you all the big
ideas in in just one slide so that where
we're going to use a recursive idea so
that the we're basically going to break
into two cases depending on how close
our vector is to that
reg hold so how close the fraction of
one's the Nexus to the threshold that we
care about and it all turned out that
this parameter Delta here is like the
how close that we'll we'll want to look
at so the first case if if if we're
really far from the threshold like not
only are we past this threshold but
we're way past it or not only are we not
above it but we're way below it then we
can do a sampling trick where you like
construct a smaller vector X tilde by
just sampling a constant fraction of the
entries of x and x like the Chernoff
bound you can see that this sampled
vector lies has the fraction of ones in
the sample vector lies on the same side
of theta with like really good
probability as the original vector did
so so we can sample the smaller vector
and didn't just solve it on like the
smaller instance of the problem and then
if the fraction of ones in our vector is
really close to the threshold then
somehow there's like intuitively there's
not really anything really great we can
do like we if we try to do something
randomized like we're so close to the
threshold that we might miss a single
one and like everything will go wrong so
here we're just going to use an exact
polynomial that you can get by
interpolation of degree like n times
delta which turns out to be root n log 1
over epsilon 4 for the threshold
function so we're just going to have a
polynomial which is exact and is
guaranteed to give us the right answer
on these inputs ok so we're constructing
a polynomial right how are we going to
decide which of these cases were in well
we're actually going to use the same
recursive idea again if we can have
threat like threshold functions for
theta plus Delta and theta minus Delta
that we substitute in the the sampled
vector which will give us a good enough
idea of which of these two cases were in
and so if the hard part here is like
maybe you were right on the border and
then which case are we going to pick and
we can we can all deal with this by like
we'll make our exact polynomial here
like the exact for a little bit more
than we actually care about like like
twice the width or something like that
so that in the middle there like no
matter which of
what these thresholds ends up saying
will still probably give the right
answer yeah so that's the idea for in to
further our construction and because of
how you end up picking Delta you get a
degree of root n log 1 over epsilon ok
so the question now is how are we going
to use probabilistic polynomials to
compute something quickly and the big
idea is to use this lemma that Ryan
proved that basically if you have a
polynomial and you divide up its its
inputs into like an exit and a why set
of inputs and then what you want to do
is evaluate this on lots and lots of
inputs so like you have some big set of
a of like X sets of vectors and some big
set B of likewise sets of inputs re and
you want you and you want to evaluate it
on all pairs of a choice of the exes and
a choice of the wise in a cross B so and
yeah these have size n a and B of size n
then normally if you just do this in the
really obvious way it would take n times
n times oh yeah we have we have this
sort of this requirement that there at
most n to the point 17 monomials for
like a technical reason so normally it
would take n times n times n to the
point 17 time to do this in the really
obvious way but using a like fast
rectangular matrix multiplication you
can actually get it down to about N
squared time and this is this is this
like surprising speed up here is where
our surprising speed up for our later
problem is going to come from yeah so
basically if you have a polynomial that
has not too many monomials then you can
evaluate it on lots and lots of points
faster than you would expect you'd be
able to so what we're going to do is use
this and our majority polynomial to
solve this subproblem of the batch
having nearest neighbor problem so its
sub problem i'll just call it the
hamming distance problem is you're given
two collections of s vectors and an
integer k and we want to determine just
weather
a choice of one vector from each
collection with Hamming distance at most
K so this is like a sub-problem we're
going to use for our bigger problem so
how do we do this well we're going to
define a polynomial for this subproblem
using our majority pulling them it's
going to be a probabilistic polynomial
again and yeah we're going to work over
f2 because we'll see like working over
f2 gives us some degree savings here so
uh so what are the ingredients of this
all first will let x1 through xs and y 1
through is be the two collections of
vectors so we're looking at there's an X
I and a YJ with Hamming distance at most
K and yeah for notation were right x i
comma j for like the Jake variable of
the vector X sub I so the first
ingredient is that we're going to use
our threshold function probabilistic
polynomial we just defined for threshold
value k plus 1 over d and this will be a
function on d inputs this is checking
whether whether or not at least k plus
one of the inputs to it are one and
we'll simple it with this error which
will make the math work out next we
later on the other ingredient is going
to be a uniformly random subset of the
set of pairs of ordered pairs of two
integers between 1 and s and Alex line
where this comes in a second but this is
like each pair come is in this set are
with probability half ok so our
polynomial is defined like this it's
going to be the sum over the pairs that
we ended up randomly picking of 1 plus
our threshold polynomial evaluated at
the the Sun like the entry wise vector
sum of x 0 x and y sub J ok here it is
again up here ok so let's see why this
why this works for our function we care
about so first of all yes where did you
use this fact that we're working over f2
here this is where we're going over f2
the sum of 2 201 variables is one when
they're not equal to each other and it's
0 when they are equal to
so the number of ones in the sub vector
is exactly the Hamming distance between
X and Y and that means that while
assuming p is is a correct is correctly
evaluating the threshold function on
this instance p evaluated at that some
is determining whether the hamming
distance between them is at least k plus
1 so 1 plus that is one if and only if
the two vectors have hearing distance at
most K okay so if all of them so okay
yeah so if all of the pairs in our if
all of the pairs of an ex I and a YJ
have Hamming distance greater than K so
this is the instance we're supposed to
return know for our problem then each of
these terms is 0 assuming the
probabilistic polynomials correct and so
this is a sum of a bunch of zeros and
it'll always return 0 meanwhile if
there's at least one pair where the
Hamming distance isn't at most K then I
claim there's there's a one half chance
that this polynomial will output a 1 and
to see this you can you can do this
trick where like you pick all the pairs
in art except for the one which is
actually going to give 0 1 in this sum
or one of them and then before having
picked this pair the the Sun was either
a 0 or 1 it doesn't really matter which
so with with one half chance this pair
will change the value of the sub so with
one half chance those value of something
is actually going to be one and once
again this is nice like one sided error
like if the answer was supposed to be
zero let sleeping our polynomial P was
correct then we're always going to say 0
so we can amplify it just like before
and here like it turns out where we're
going to need to take like two two
samples of this to get the probability
that we want of success yeah there's
there's some more details about like
making sure the probability P is correct
is high enough but I claim that it works
out okay so we have now have this nice
polynomial for the sub-problem and there
are two steps left the first is to
actually get from this polynomial to an
algorithm for the Hamming
since problem which I'll remind you
again checking whether there is a pair
with distance at most K and the second
step is getting from this subproblem to
the problem we want to solve the batch
having nearest neighbor problem where
for each of the vectors you want to find
its nearest neighbor which is like a
seemingly harder problem I guess okay so
let's start with the first one and
there's interesting because this is
where the the weird see log squared C
thing is going to come from okay so yeah
so so if R and D are two sets of vectors
of dimension D they both have size N and
D is like C log n then and finally we're
given a value k then we can find a
vector V from our and a vector you from
be who's hemming distances at most K in
time n to the 2-1 over order see log
square C or determined that none exists
okay how do we do this well we're so
we're going to use our polynomial we
just defined for this problem right so
we first partition each of r & b into n
of RS groups of size s where NSS is
going to be this one over order see log
square c value so what we do is yeah so
we take our probabilistic polynomial we
just defined and you can see that if you
if you look at the degree of the
construction we made each each this
polynomial has degree route de la guess
the error was like 1 over s cubed or
something like this so the number of
monomials is going to be something like
2d 2d log s and here I'm hiding some
like polynomial terms outside the
binomial coefficient that don't really
affect what the number of monomials ends
up being and and the important thing to
note here is that if we choose on big
enough constant inside this like size of
the group over here then we can make
this binomial coefficient be at most n
to the point 174 for any like s and DNA
ever so yeah so in other words this was
exactly the size s we needed to make our
tamika's able to use our probabilistic
polynomial inside the fast evaluation
technique with rectangular matrix
multiplication from before and any and
here's here's the part where if the
degree of the probabilistic polynomial
were any bigger this wouldn't work
because if we had like an extra log.d
term here this this binomial coefficient
would be too big to ever give at most n
to the point 17 monomials with a
significant saving in in the size s here
alright so using the fast evaluation we
can then evaluate the polynomial on all
the pairs of groups in this much time
and and then I guess this this will tell
us based on whether any of them returns
one or not whether there is a pair with
this is that most K and then the last
look trick is just like if there is such
a group we can actually just brute force
to find which pair of vectors it is
because these the S is so small compared
to N squared okay so that that's the
first level and then the second one to
actually get whereas we actually have to
get from that Hamming distance problem
to the seemingly harder batch Hamming
nearest neighbor problem and here we're
actually going to use a nice like fine
Drake grained reduction kind of thing I
think like maybe this exact same idea
came up at the the workshop a couple
weeks ago so the idea is we're going to
show that if you can solve the Hamming
distance problem in time T of N and D
then you can solve the batch hemming
nearest neighbor problem in time n times
d times T of root ND so like we're going
to do it on on instances of size root
and instead of size n the and the idea
it's like a partitioning thing again we
partition the set d of database vectors
and the set to you of query vectors into
root n size groups of size root n and
then for each K from 0 up to D minus 1
we're going to we're going to go and
find all the query
vectors to you that have Hamming
distance k from something in D and then
like remove them basically so we start
from k from zero and we go up to dys one
and what we do is we call our Hamming
distance problem algorithm for each of
the pairs of one of the groups from D
and one of the groups from Q so they're
like root end groups from DN root end
groups of keeps their end of the use in
total and then for each of these groups
if we find a pair of a vector U and a
vector V that has this having distance k
then that means that V is a
nearest-neighbor for you so we can
remove you say the answer for that one
is K and continue and like will believe
and repeat on that group again and if if
we don't if if we call to that group and
they say none of them have distance that
most K will just continue to the next
group so yeah so yeah I guess whenever
we like call this for the correct k on
the group compared containing the two
vectors that actually have the smallest
Hamming distance then we should find the
correct pair for vector U and the nice
thing to note is that we'll we'll call
this like D times n times and is the
number of pairs or groups plus at most
one more for each time we actually find
one of these pairs in queue which isn't
just another n so the total number of
times we call the sub algorithm is just
n type order n times d and we're calling
it on on instances of size square root
of n instead of size n so we get this
time I wrote over here yeah and then you
know finally substitute in the time we
got for the subproblem and you get
exactly the running time for the
original problem that I told you at the
beginning yes that's about it I guess I
guess just to summarize these these
these probabilistic polynomials are
pretty cool because in the past they are
mainly used for like circuit lower bound
kind of techniques like like the result
by brazzer province molinsky lower
banding the degree
you have a probabilistic polynomial for
majority was originally used to get low
depth Circuit lower bounds for the
majority function but here we use it and
I like sort of completely different way
to actually make some small computations
really fast and by combining this with
rectangular matrix multiplication tricks
we can like do lots and lots of Hamming
distance computations in like faster
than you would expect to be able to so
that's that's really where this order
see logs kurti Zeke term comes from yeah
and I guess I'm kind of hungry you guys
are probably hungry so i'll just stuff
now yeah
so what the other functions from which
if you can get the polynomial and you
get a very agreeable some in the
industry ah probably I would thinking
about this of it I guess yeah I like if
there any like algorithmic problems
where you can find a nice like sub
computation you do a lot of times that I
think it's a good candidate for this
method
yep as opposed fast matrix
multiplication is still sort of two sub
quadratic time for yeah it's it's yeah
it's really the savings there that go
onto the savings here yeah i guess the
weird thing is that like improving
rectangular matrix multiplication
probably wouldn't help anymore here like
the point 17 and the exponents it
doesn't really make much of a difference